keegan aiken will
face second
start of the season
they did
yeah he did they appeal and they ring
them up yeah you could hear brandon
hides voice out of the dugout he was
helping yeah in case tom hallian behind
the plate needed any help
terrific one two three no score
and down he goes
hedges down on strike standing yeah you
cannot throw a better slider if late on
the high fast ball fastballs away well
24 year old jc mejia will be making his
uh first major league start six foot
five 240 pounds you can see the three
outings he's been very good
swinging a miss and mejia has his first
strikeout two down very good movement on
the two-seamer here
keeps it low and it just keeps bearing
down
boy the hitters really got to use their
legs if they want to go down and hit
that pitch
yeah he's going to learn down the road
but they let him throw a two-seam
fastball and zimmer's down on strikes
well there's a good slider and this
stuff is too good for lefties and
perfect slider strike to ball pedro
severino
swing and a miss that's a good pitch and
make mejia has his second strikeout
tonight one down used to seeing that
ball coming in you see he's looking for
it coming in and it's going away he's
performing
that's that's the
the great thing
he's back to normal there's your double
play ball is it two for one yes yes sir
mahia gets out of it and after three no
score in baltimore
[Applause]
and he got him looking
down on strikes goes austin hedges it's
almost like he's saying what was i
looking for
kind of a quizzical look on his face
fastball inside corner that's the
thought you know again we talked about
deception jose ramirez one for two that
single in the third means he's reached
safely in 19
consecutive games
brown ball and he finds the hole beats
the shift
his second hit of the night harold
ramirez walked in the second then had a
chance with two on and two out in the
third but grounded into an inning ending
fielder's choice harold going the other
way is it in the alley you bet it is all
the way off the wall and it takes a
crazy care of by mullins ramirez will
score easily harold's going for three
he's gonna go in standing with an rbi
triple this is not a great triples
ballpark but he hit it in the absolute
perfect spot for one the ricochet here
it's going to get past
mullins in center field and it ricochets
past him that little angle there on the
fence and that enabled you to get a
triple had allowed ramirez to score so
they finally put one in play goes off
the wall and there goes ramirez into
third he will give the indians a
one-nothing lead he'll get his first
triple so lead off watt to start off the
orioles seven here's ryan modcastle
looking for his first contact of the
night a couple of strikeouts
that's hit well left field
way back
at the wall
and it is
gone four bases home run well they're
signaling a home run that's the call
third base umpire adam beck
signaled home run and ryan mom castle
has given the orioles a 2-1 lead number
seven for ryan
well you talked about maybe running into
one and he did here goes rosario up oh i
don't know
yeah i'm sure they're going to have him
look at it but they weren't in the field
of play doesn't matter but if they
interfere in the field of play now i
don't know if they're going to reverse
it i think they were in the stands it's
not like they reached over well you'll
see yeah so there's the glove
and the ball over it yeah there's no way
they're going to change that but he did
take one for the club ouch
get him a baseball at least give him a
souvenir touch them all there's the
secret
tom hallian for the home run call hey
high fives ryan mount castle so one
nothing goes to two to one
anthony coming in with runners in
scoring position
orioles have one grand slam this year
that was ryan mout castle witkin ready
2-2
high-fly ball left field severino will
tag at third
rosario with the grab strong throw but
it sails
all the way
to whit grin who was backing up the play
in the orioles tack on a run santander
with the rbi sac fly
so here's your sacrifice slide tony
mancellino giving him go
and here's your throw you talked about
but here again for the umpteenth time
as that ball is hit on the ground
ramirez will go to second for one on the
first
ending an inning ending double play
and they're going to turn it over to yet
another left hander this is paul fry on
for the 23rd time this year looking for
his second save
two out of the three hitters scheduled
left-handers eddie rosario josh naylor
owen miller the right-handed bat
sandwiched in between well you can see
21 and two-thirds innings 32 strikeouts
lines that one into right field for a
base hit and now you bring the tying run
to the plate
seventh hit of the night for cleveland
well he throws the fastball right by him
and then comes back with an inside
breaking ball and left it upstairs eddie
took advantage of a mistake gets a base
hit so they can bring the tying run to
the plate down in the count two strikes
and down he goes
out number one
didn't waste a whole lot of time three
sliders in a row this one as good as any
of them
[Music]
he hits it on the ground that way cut
off by the third baseman they get one
but
will not turn the double play nice job
by franco
to shovel it over to wilkerson to get
the lead runner and there are two down
yeah it just wasn't hit hard enough get
it to them make sure you get the first
one they tried to turn it
they're down to their last out now
getting an opportunity to bat here
well you chang
has hit in the last two games he's
played but over seven is a pinch hitter
and a line drive right field gets down
base hit they're still alive here
with two on and two out so you change
his first pinch hit of the season
well he got a fastball to his liking and
takes it the other way and that's pretty
much his swing he likes to go the other
way there's the fastball away stay down
it nicely line drive to right keeps this
ball game going
now
tying runs are aboard two on two down
and the cleveland ninth orioles on top
3-1
[Applause]
they should do it bounce to galves on to
first and the orioles win it
three straight for the birds